[Music] foreign
So it's been a pretty interesting series of
discussions on differential equations anddynamical systems.
In the last few videos I've
shown you how to integrate differential equations
and systems of differential equations. Even if
they're non-linear we can integrate them on a
computer using numerical simulation techniques
like Runge-Kutta schemes or Euler schemes and
I mentioned in passing that there are certain
systems that are chaotic, that are especially
hard to simulate... to integrate accurately
forward in time. They amplify uncertainty and
errors exponentially in forward time and so today
I'm going to dive in a little bit more to what I
mean by chaos and chaotic systems. I'm going to
give you some definitions and some examples and
we're also going to work out with math some of
the implications of what it means to be chaotic
and how we can interpret these solutions and
also it'll give us an idea of what we might be
able to do to improve our numerical algorithms
to simulate these kinds of tricky systems.
So this is a video in Python and Matlab
to simulate the Lorentz 1963 problem, this
chaotic system of three differential equations,
and what I did was I took an initial condition
and added a cube of uncertainty... this red cube
of uncertainty... and integrated all of those
trajectories forward in time. And you can see
that the trajectories initially stay together but
after a very short amount of time they start to
stretch and fold and mix onto this chaotic Lorenz
attractor. So this is kind of pictorial evidence
of the first main point I want to make which is
oftentimes chaos is defined as a system that has
sensitive dependence on its initial conditions. So
you can think of this red blob of uncertainty as
some uncertainty in my initial condition and very
soon as I integrate this this dynamical system
that uncertainty grows and grows and grows until
after some finite amount of time that initial grid
of particles could be anywhere on this attractor.
This is in stark contrast to a non-chaotic
system such as a pendulum or a mass on a spring
where even if the pendulum is non-linear... it has
non-linear terms "d^2/dt theta = -sin(theta)" it
still does not have the sensitive dependence on
initial conditions. If I start with a blob of
initial conditions around some nominal "theta" and
I let all of those go they're going to basically
stay together in the same kind of clockwork and
there will be some predictability in the future
based based on those initial conditions, whereasin a chaotic system you truly have this sensitivedependence on initial conditions.
And so thatactually causes some big issues... for example,when we talked about our numerical integrators
we were trying to find some numerical trajectory,
let's say you know I have x_0 and then I want to
integrate it forward to get some x_1 and integrate
that forward to x_2 and so on and so forth and we
developed schemes like the Runge-Kutta scheme and
analyze the error properties at each time step.
And so for example we showed that the fourth order
Runga Kutta a scheme has error that is on the
order of delta T to the fifth power where delta
T is my time Step at every single step of the
integrator I have order delta T to the fifth error
now for deterministic systems what you can do
this is this is what's called the so-called
local error this is um kind of local uh at each
DT at each delta T and for a deterministic system
not like this chaotic system but more like the
pendulum system you can compute from this local
error what is the global error across the
trajectory because essentially these errors
will just add up and each time step you're
accruing this order delta T to the Fifth Air
and the length of my trajectory you know if I
make delta T smaller I have more steps for that
to accrue and so the global error is often uh just
this number divided by delta T so the global error
would normally be order delta T to the fourth
true for chaotic systems This Global error
doesn't make sense for chaotic systems I'm
about to show you why so this is not
true for chaos or for chaotic systems
and the reason is is because at each little time
step when I accrue this very very small order
delta T to the fifth error so I have you know I
take one time step and my simulated trajectory
deviates from my true trajectory by some teeny
tiny little Epsilon so instead of going to X1 I
go to X1 plus Epsilon that Epsilon so you know
I basically go to X One Plus Epsilon that's the
error in my numerical scheme it's teeny tiny but
over time because of the sensitive dependence on
initial conditions because of a chaotic system
my this Epsilon is going to grow exponentially
in forward time so my my trajectory my simulated
trajectory and my true trajectory are going to
diverge even if I'm only introducing these teeny
tiny little order delta T to the fifth errors at
every time step so the way that these local errors
compound for chaotic systems is way way worse than
for non-chaotic systems and so this notion of
global error that we think of for pendula and
spring Mass dampers just doesn't apply to chaotic
systems it's much worse than that you essentially
have something like each of these little errors
these little local delta T errors at every time
step get magnif to magnified by some exponential
function some e to the Lambda T where Lambda is a
positive number called the lyapan of exponent
liabunov exponent and that essentially says
that every single time step these little errors
are growing exponentially in time and so this
is going to motivate better integrators or at
least different integrators for these chaotic
systems oftentimes so for example if I have a
hamiltonian system or some mechanical system
governed by the Euler LaGrange equations there
are special custom tailor-made integrators that
are designed for those systems if they're chaotic
to to give you better properties and kind of stay
on the solution manifold more Faithfully okay so
I'll tell you about that a little bit more in a
minute I'll just mention here that leaponov this
is one of the most controversially spelled names
in all of mathematics I think I've seen at least
three different spellings of leaponov this is the
one I grew up with so this is the one I'm using
that when you Google the App and on there's going
to be like at least three different ways to spell
this and so often what we try to do is we try to
use a small enough delta T that our runga cutter
error is actually very very small to begin with
so order delta T to the fifth we want that to be
as close to machine precision as possible you know
10 to the minus 12 10 to the minus 16. but even if
this Epsilon is 10 to the minus 16 for a positive
Lambda it doesn't take very long for this error
to grow to order one to a big significant error in
our in our simulation and last thing I'll point
out before I give you some examples is in this
chaotic lorentz system because the trajectory is
kind of bound to this white attractor this is the
so-called strange attractor or the lorentz
butterfly attractor that that Epsilon grows
initially exponentially but then eventually uh it
the trajectory is still stuck adhering onto this
um this strange attractor and so I can actually
get away with using something like rk4 if all I
care about is the rough shape of this attractor or
the rough statistics of this tractor maybe I don't
care if this is the exact uh perfect trajectory
that that initial condition would take this is
a representative trajectory because it's going
to you know do the representative thing uh on
this Lorentz system if I wanted a you know very
quantitatively accurate trajectory that followed
the exact true Dynamics I might need to use
something more fancy than a runga cutter scheme so
we'll come back to this in a minute and we'll talk
more about these kind of numerical considerations
the other examples I like to think about
so this is kind of one of our canonical
simplest examples it's a three-state
ode that happens to be chaotic.
The solar system is another great example.
Chaos was actually discovered, or
at least codifiedmathematically
by Henri Poincare in the early 1900s... I think
it might have been 1906,right around the time
Einstein was making his great discoveries.
Poincare was solidifying this theory of
chaotic dynamical systems, and actually a lot of
the dynamical systems and differential equations
that we use even to this day come from Poincare
about a century ago. And so the idea is that there
are chaotic trajectories in the solar system.
And it's pretty easy to understand this if you
think about... I don't know it's a little hard to
see but let's pretend that that's Earth and let's
pretend that the Moon is somewhere over here...
but between the Earth and the moon there is this
equal gravity point, this saddle point. It's
literally a fixed point of that dynamical system
where it has saddle eigenvalues, so it has one
positive real and one negative real eigenvalue,
and what that means is if I am at this equal
gravity point between the Earth and the moon,
and I'm perfectly on that point then I'll stay at
that equal spacing... that equal gravity distance
between the Earth and the moon but if I perturb
myself a teeny tiny bit towards the moon I'll
accelerate towards the moon, and if I perturb
myself a teeny tiny bit towards the Earth I'll
accelerate towards the Earth. And so you can see
that at least locally to that fixed point I get
this exponential splitting of my trajectories
because of that saddle point and so that is
one of the hallmark features in chaos is that
usually there is some kind of a saddle point
that's mediating the stretching and exponential
growth of trajectories in that system. Actually
if I go back to this Lorenz system you'll see
that this bundle of trajectories actually stays
pretty close together until it gets close to this
saddle point here. So it's still on the same lobe,
but now they're going to pull down and get
close to the saddle point and that's what
causes them to really stretch in this
exponential positive Lyapunov exponent way.
And I'll mention that this this technically these
trajectories don't split monotonically... the
separation between two neighboring trajectories
with this sensitive dependence on initial
conditions it's not monotonic exponential growth;
it's on average exponential growth. Sometimes
they come closer together before they move apart
and it's usually driven by how close they get to
these saddle points. So saddle points are really
essential in this picture of chaos. Again this is
a whole class that I hope to offer at some point
in the future... many lectures and hours of videos
here. I'm just giving you the very high level,
especially as it relates to how do you numerically
simulate ordinary differential equations. And
so in the solar system I want to point out that
having a saddle doesn't mean you are guaranteed
to be chaotic, it just means you locally will have
trajectories separate. Consider a pendulum... if
I look at the pendulum up condition that also has
a saddle point, and trajectories will diverge
locally in time but in a very predictable way.
But if I have enough saddles and I have a
high enough dimensional system like this
interplanetary solar system network, often times
that gives rise to really chaotic trajectories
and it turns out in this case you can actually
harness these chaotic trajectories and harness
this exponential growth for very efficient
transport to very different regions of the
solar system. That's kind of depicted here in this
artist's representation, is that if I can get near
one of these points where I get this very large
sensitivity and this large spreading, then with
a small amount of fuel burn, a little "Delta V"
of my rocket ship, I can go from ... I can jump
from this tube to this tube and go to completely
different places in the solar system for for
small amounts of energy. Now this epsilon would be
like a small amount of energy, and it allows me to
to get this large amplification. So chaos is not
always a bad thing, but it is hard to predict and
it's hard to simulate, and it's hard to estimate.
There are in fact special integrators used
to to integrate this dynamical system from our
various global space agencies for super computer
simulations of what the solar system and all of
its objects will look like at some time in the
future. And these are very very tricky simulations
because of the chaotic nature of the system.
To give in my class a sensitive dependence
on initial condition is the double pendulum.
The double pendulum is probably the simplest
mechanical system that exhibits chaos. And by
double pendulum I literally mean it's one pendulum
with another pendulum attached to it... so there's
two "thetas" there's theta_1 and theta_2 and this
double pendulum you can picture how this thing
would would swing and maybe do some pretty crazy
things so what I did was I actually build this for
my first class ever teaching here at University
of Washington. I built an apparatus where I have
two double pendulum right next to each other,
so it's called the tandem double pendulum. I got
this idea from the controls and dynamical systems
library at Caltech where I believe Jerry Marsden
was gifted a tandem double pendulum. So it's two
double pendula right next to each other and you
can start them at the same initial condition and
when you let them go they their trajectories do
agree for a little while, and then at some point
they diverge because of this sensitive dependence
on initial conditions. So I built one of those for
my class and that's what we're visualizing here I
start them at the same initial condition and then
let go they're actually agreeing pretty well until
they don't and now they've diverged into totally
different solutions. Small changes in the initial
condition, small changes in the system parameters
-- the friction, the length of the pendula -- will
eventually cause these trajectories to diverge in
this kind of exponential Lyapunov exponent way,
which is really cool. And you can try this thing
from different initial conditions... maybe at some
point I'll take a video outside ... actually I
tried to bring it in here but the lighting is
just not good enough for these, they kind of
blend in... and we can try different initial
conditions so for example if I start with my my
tandem double pendulum where they're both in the
down down position and I perturb them a small
amount they actually that is not chaotic they
basically will act like little pendulum clocks and
they'll almost perfectly track each other forever
until they die out to zero um and I actually chose
this initial condition where you know one of them
was at this kind of 90 degree angle because that
is an initial condition that has enough energy
that you kind of excite the chaos in the system
and so that's another key principle here is that
a lot of times for mechanical systems for the
the planetary Dynamics there is a certain energy
level above which uh these chaotic Dynamics are
really excited and activated and again it has
to do with the saddle points in the system so in
this uh this double pendulum system the pendulum
uh if I if I linearize the Dynamics we know
how to linearize the Dynamics the down down
um configuration just the kind of really easy
down down configuration with you know small
perturbations that is actually a linear center
it's got a plus or minus I Omega plus or minus
I Omega eigenvalues and so it's neutrally stable
it's not chaotic but when I increase the energy
and so now I have the first pendulum arm down and
the second pendulum arm up so kind of the down
up configuration if I linearize this system you
should do this yourself at home if you linearize
these Dynamics you'll find out that it has a
saddle Direction in that fixed Point there's
one set of plus minus real eigenvalues and this
saddle point is where the chaos comes from so if
I start with energy Above This saddle point I'll
get chaotic Solutions like this so that's why I
start from that initial condition because this
is where you'll see that sensitive dependence
on initial conditions is for energies Above This
saddle point we actually just wrote a couple of
cool papers showing that the Dynamics of this
pendulum are almost mathematically identical to
the Dynamics of the the three body problem that
we've been studying you know for over 100 years
in in planetary Dynamics making this double
pendulum kind of a cool tabletop experiment
to start understanding chaotic transport in the
solar system and again in both of those systems
we need good numerical integrators and we need to
understand how our error grows through these these
chaotic systems through this sensitive dependence
on initial conditions again that's the key Point
here is sensitive dependence on initial conditions
you're going to hear that over and over again
there are other things people use to describe
chaos kind of Hallmark features but that's really
the one that I always keep coming back to is um
that you know a small change in initial conditions
often gets Amplified kind of exponentially
at least for a while in these chaotic systems
good uh and you can actually you know since I
built this about 10 years ago we've actually built
a few much better experimental rigs in the lab so
you can control a chaotic system so we've pumped
in a lot of energy so it's well above the chaotic
threshold but with feedback control and with a
good enough integration scheme a good enough kind
of model predictive controller we can actually
swing this pendulum up and stabilize a condition
that's normally unstable and definitely with
enough energy that you would classify if I let
the system go it would have a chaotic Dynamic okay
this is actually the the third generation double
pendulum that we built in my lab I think we're on
to the fourth generation now which is even kind of
fancier and nicer than this where you can do all
kinds of cool acrobatic control again using the
fact leveraging this chaotic Dynamics to put in
only a small amount of energy at the right time
and using kind of the internal chaotic Dynamics
to to get the system to behave the way you want
it to so really cool stuff again just just kind
of illustrating that you can in fact control
these systems uh sometimes if you're lucky okay
I want to tell you about um so we've talked about
how chaotic systems involve this exponential
growth of small perturbations mathematically maybe
I want to show you actually mathematically how you
would write this down because I think this
is pretty useful so let's say you have your
differential equation uh x dot equals f of x now
technically this could vary in time as well this
could be f of x comma T no big deal nothing's
going to change and what I write it's just a
little more complicated and often what we will
say is that um the numerical solution X at some
future time T is equal to X naught exit time 0.
plus an integral from times 0 to time T of the
Dynamics F of and now X is is my trajectory X is
my trajectory which is a function of time and so
you evaluate F at each of these intermediate times
from 0 to T along a trajectory and you integrate
this up using a dummy variable Tau now you can
kind of carefully convince yourself you know
that this is in fact how how you would integrate
the system mathematically this is kind of an
idealization of what we would do in these these
rangakatta schemes or Euler schemes this is like
a mathematical expression that if you perfectly
did this integral and you perfectly integrated up
all of these contributions of f to x dot and kept
adding those up along along the trajectory and you
kept updating f as X changed as X moves along that
trajectory then this will step your your system
forward in time and oftentimes I call this the the
flow map operator sometimes I call this this big
flow map from 0 to T of some X naught and it steps
me forward from t 0 to T to time T okay this is a
mathematical object and what we'll find is that
for chaotic systems so this is actually like the
one of the first papers I ever wrote In fact the
first paper I ever wrote when I was a grad student
was about analyzing the properties of this flow
map when you add a teeny perturbation when you
add a little Epsilon to your X so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say what if I had instead
of X naught I had X naught plus an Epsilon so if
I have Phi you know my flow map I'm integrating uh
from X naught but what if I have X naught plus
an Epsilon plus a teeny tiny little Epsilon of
perturbation and this Epsilon could be from a
numerical artifact it could be 10 to the minus
16 round off error in how I stored this it could
be an order delta T to the fifth error for my
runga cut a scheme whatever it is I want to know
how that error propagates through this flow map
and so you can tailor expand this because
this Epsilon is small so we can tailor
expand around this is a function it's a
it's a smooth function typically and so
I can tailor expand and this is going to equal
the flow map that I want this V 0 t of X naught
plus the Jacobian of this flow
map plus d uh let's say d Phi DX
yeah zero to T evaluated at X naught times my
Epsilon plus I could write out more and more
terms plus higher order terms in epsilon plus
order let's say epsilon squared and higher terms
okay and so essentially this is the true flow map
this is the true trajectory X at time T this is
what I actually want and this is my leading error
term so this is my kind of leading error term
leading error and this is actually how we compute
this Lambda at least approximately for for finite
time trajectories for finite time t uh kind
of the leading eigenvalue of well the leading
singular value of this Matrix of derivatives
evaluated at X naught is going to give me an
estimate of my my lyapana of exponent Lambda
because essentially what this does is this says
this Jacobian this is a matrix when I evaluate
this set of partial derivatives with respect to
X naught this is a matrix and I can compute this
numerically using things like the finite timely
opponent of exponent so I have a whole video
on that you can check out of how to actually
compute this thing and approximate it from
trajectory data but the long story short is that
this is a matrix when I evaluated at X naught
and it tells me that that Matrix has you know
eigenvalues and eigenvectors and singular values
and singular vectors there are directions that
that Matrix makes bigger and there's directions
that that Matrix makes smaller and so if my error
is aligned with one of the bad directions of this
this amplifying Matrix then my error is going to
get Amplified and so what we find is that this
Matrix has oftentimes for chaotic systems this
Matrix will have large singular values meaning
there are directions that if error is in that
direction those will get Amplified exponentially
and so what you do mathematically I'll just write
this down in case you're curious you don't have
to understand all the steps there's a whole video
and a whole papers about this is that you could
basically pick the max singular value of this dvdx
and that is going to equal essentially
approximately this e to the Lambda T so
you could approximately your lyapanov exponent
Lambda by taking the logarithm of this the maximum
singular value and dividing by the integration
time T so that gives you a way of estimating how
this error propagates through your system and this
kind of synthesizes a lot of things we thought
about in this series on differential equations
so this is the perfect trajectory integration
scheme if I had infinitesimal truly DT delta T
is like truly calculus infinitesimal DTS this
would be exact and true this would give me the
trajectory at any point in time but we know that
we're chopping up our trajectory into finite Delta
T's that accrue some error some Epsilon error and
so if I assume that at each time step I introduce
this error Epsilon maybe it's even 10 to the minus
16. maybe I have an amazing integrator and it's
as good as my computer can represent numbers but
I'm still going to have some representation error
10 to the minus 16 at the you know best case here
I can tailor expand that out and I get these
interesting terms for my Taylor series where I can
isolate that this is the leading error term and
the point I'm trying to make is that for chaotic
systems this leading error term amplifies like e
to the Lambda T okay which is a big deal that's
really bad that means that even my 10 to the minus
16 error is going to amplify and stretch and grow
and so there's ways you can control that and
there's ways you can understand how big that
Lambda is numerically using these finite
Timely app on all exponents by actually
Computing the singular value decomposition
of this or if you like the eigenvalue
decomposition of this times its transpose
um the koshy green stress stress tensor
um so I think that that's pretty interesting
uh something else I think I want to to tell
you about is if I take a mechanical system like
this double pendulum so in fact exactly like
this double pendulum let's assume that there is
no friction on these bearings so we're going to
make an idealized you know perfect hamiltonian
system or lagrangian system of no dissipation we
know that the energy should be conserved in this
system okay so if I literally plot you know energy
versus time there should be a constant line
for any trajectory that I integrate starting
from X naught to some x t that energy should
be constant now this is actually a really good
exercise you should write down the double
pendulum equations of motion you can do
this from the Euler LaGrange equations or from
the hamiltonian equations pretty pretty easy to
do it's a little messy you're going to get all
the Sines and cosines right but it's not so hard
and you should write down an rk4 integrator for
that problem and simulate that trajectory forward
in time and compute the energy at each time step
and what you'll find is that the energy of the rk4
is going to be a mess it's going to diverge from
this constant maybe it'll go to negative Infinity
maybe it'll go to positive Infinity but it's not
going to be a constant it's far from a constant
when you integrate these mechanical systems
basic basic fundamental conservation laws
like conservation of energy are being violated and
like truly violated here um I feel violated when
I integrate A system that should be conservative
with an RK scheme and you should too and so there
are better numerical algorithms for integrating
these kinds of chaotic systems if there's that
additional structure if we know that our system
is hamiltonian so for hamiltonian systems
uh hamiltonian there are integrators
called simplexic integrators simplexic
and they essentially let's say symplectic
integrators there's some really good algorithms
out there for some plectic integrators where
essentially we know that hamiltonian systems
generally have this kind of um skew symmetric
structure between positions and momentum so
that you have something something some some
skew symmetric structure like this in your
equations and what simplectic integrators do is
that they build the numerical updating scheme so
that every time step this is this structure
is exactly preserved so if you like all of
these errors even when they accrue they are
still being kind of projected back onto a
manifold where the basic physics the basic
energy conservation is being satisfied so
those algorithms like a simplectic maybe I'll
make this in green something like simplectic
you know even when the integrator tries to you
know pull it off of this energy surface it's
kind of constantly correcting it and staying very
very close to that energy surface so these are
Reef you want to integrate you know a spaceship
through the solar system or if you want to know
how a space rock is going to be hurtling
through the solar system you better be using
a smart integrator or else you're going
to get garbage you're not going to know
if it's going to hit Earth in 50 years or not
because your simulator is completely off base
okay just like there are simplectic integrators
there are also and that preserves hamiltonian
structure structure if you have something that is
you know if you want to start from the lagrangian
um which these are kind of equivalent um you
know ways of representing mechanical systems
the Euler LaGrange equations if you want to
discreetly in a computer integrator satisfy
the lagrangian the Euler LaGrange equations these
are called variational integrators variational and
I might you know I spent a lot of time developing
variational and simplexic integrators in research
and you know back um you know a decade ago
maybe I'll have a whole video on variational
and simplexic integrators because they're so
important for integrating hard chaotic systems
where you really need to know uh good trajectories
good answers for a specific initial condition
again in that lorentz case I was showing you I
just wanted to know kind of the statistics of how
things happened and so it didn't really matter I
wasn't I didn't care about that single trajectory
and where it went as much as the statistics but if
I'm following an asteroid or you know a space Rock
in the solar system I really want to know that
specific trajectory where it's going to be I need
these better variational and simplexic integrators
now it turns out kind of a fun happenstance that
a an rk78 integrator this is sometimes called
the rkf the runga cut of felberg seven eight
rkf78 it turns out that our kf78 is nearly
symplectic for lots of problems and so it's
actually an amazing integrator it has kind of all
of the properties of an RK integrator very small
single step error so very accurate and single
steps and it approximately is simplectic on
lots of problems I couldn't tell you why to be
honest this is something I've heard people say
and I've observed it myself that when you
simulate these chaotic systems this tends
to work much much better than this because of some
structural property here so that's interesting too
um good yeah so this is really important
um and and you you sometimes need these these
better uh integrators you know again for for
things like control applications I can't have my
energy blowing up in my model prediction uh for
really tricky prediction problems I can't have my
my error blowing up for these systems okay good
that I think are really cool so I'm going
to bring up some more videos I'm going to
erase this really quickly and then bring
up those videos and then I'll conclude
foreign and I'll also point out I got
this interesting advice once when I was an
undergraduate that you know a human life is also
chaotic it feels very chaotic sometimes sometimes
it feels more deterministic sometimes it feels
fully chaotic um but you know the choices you
make can often have these large kind of Divergent
effects right so this is a it's an interesting
it's an interesting meta perspective that you know
small changes to what you do can add up to large
changes over time uh and so you know understanding
having some model predictive control understanding
where you think you're going and where you
want to go and figuring out you know am I at
one of these critical points where things could
go totally differently and you know if in those
cases I'm going to slow down I'm going to decrease
my delta T I'm going to think harder uh about you
know about what decisions decisions I'm making
so anyway kind of interesting I thought that was
uh that was fun this was like a cocktail party
when I was an undergrad and and uh Jerry Marsden
told me about you know like the butterfly
effect and how decisions you know you make
now can make a big difference later on and he was
absolutely right okay so some other cool examples
fluid flows are often chaotic and so specifically
turbulence when someone talks about turbulence
or a turbulent fluid flow often we model that
turbulence as a chaotic dynamical system so there
is a deep deep relationship for you know many
decades researchers in turbulence have studied
chaotic dynamical systems and researchers in chaos
have used turbulence to motivate what they're
doing I feel like I'm getting a little bit trapped
here and so this is a cool example of a thermal
convection you have a hot plate on the bottom
and a cold plate on top and you get this kind of
thermal convection this is actually exactly what
lorentz was uh was studying in this Lorenz 1963
model was the chaotic convection in the Earth's
atmosphere so you know the Noonday Sun let's say
you wake up in the morning the Sun starts beating
down on the planes it heats up the planes and it
creates these large thermal convection patterns
you often get big thunderstorms and supercell
clouds and things like that and this system can be
at least approximated by this chaotic differential
equation on the right and so this um you know was
observed that similar conditions from day to day
at you know starting conditions can often
lead to very very different cloud formation
and weather formation and precipitation and all
kinds of things that are captured in this model
so this uncertainty and sensitivity of chaotic
convection was captured in this 1963 Lorenz model
I always add Fetter and Hamilton um Linda
Fetter and Margaret Hamilton when I put
this author list down because they were
the grad students who actually ran the
simulations that Lorenzo used to build these
models by modern collaboration standards they
would almost certainly be co-authors on that
work and I don't think we should forget their
contribution to this extremely important
chaotic dynamical system that we all use
um and more generally in fluid dynamics you
can kind of picture how this this chaos arises
if you think about sensitive dependence on
initial conditions this is super cool work
um by the kth group I love this video I've
used this video before and I'm a huge fan of
their their simulations and their work where they
simulate this super super high fidelity numerical
simulation of the turbulence over over wings and
things like that and so the fluid flow itself is
chaotic if I perturbed one of these vortices by
even a little bit the flow the exact configuration
would change quite rapidly and give you a totally
different distribution so it would give you the
same distribution of vortices but a different
instance a different realization this Vortex
might be over here and this one might be over
here and things like that so small changes in
the flow field itself will cause the flow field
to change over time things get Amplified as it
goes through this flow and down here small changes
up here will have big changes down here that's one
one interpretation of chaos another one that I
like is imagine you're a little particle this is
kind of fun or a little particle and we're you
know in this flow if I start one Epsilon to the
left or one Epsilon to the right I'm going to get
pulled into a whole different network of vortices
and my path is going to be completely different
even with a teeny tiny Epsilon perturbation to
my initial condition so a lot of Chaos in this
system as well and this is where I want to point
out you know when I was kind of growing up in
dynamical systems I was deep into this three-body
problem Solar System Dynamics planetary Dynamics
fluid dynamics where chaos is just a part of our
life it's everywhere and I kind of thought to
myself well how could you possibly have a high
dimensional dynamical system with the x dot equals
f of x that wasn't chaotic and I met some friends
in grad school who had high dimensional dynamical
systems that were in fact very much non-chaotic
and they actually kind of self-organized and
self-ordered if you think about it your body
is an incredibly High dimensional incredibly
High dimensional dynamical system and all there
although there are aspects of chaos locally it's
extremely well regulated and ordered and kind of
these emergent patterns reinforce and and persist
right like your metabolic regulation kind of says
that at least those variables are not diverging
you can you can eat a Snickers bar or I can skip
lunch and typically you know those perturbations
don't cause my system to go completely chaotic
sometimes they can certainly but you have a lot of
kind of stability and determinism built into this
very high dimensional system so clearly chaos is
not a universal property of all dynamical systems
so even in really really complicated fluid flows
oftentimes you get these coherent structures these
patterns that keep coming up and keep forming
over and over again even in very turbulent flows
that this is locally chaotic but there are these
large-scale emergent synchronizations and patterns
um you know this you can see I
think this is a great example this
um flow this is an atmospheric flow past Guadalupe
Island where again this is a chaotic system we
know that weather is chaotic fundamentally
and fluid Flows In in general are also but
you still get the emergence of these large-scale
structures and so one of the my favorite videos is
this uh metronome synchronization video so I've
been playing this for my class for the last 10
years I love this video where you basically have
this initial condition so someone comes in and
they start all these these uh metronomes these
little pendulum at different initial conditions
and um so that's totally disorganized and
I'm going to turn up my volume here because
I kind of actually want you to hear all
the clicking they're all over the place
and you'll notice that they're on this kind
of table that is Loosely able to vibrate so
sometimes the example I've seen you can build
one of these at home you take two cans of you
know Soda Coke and you put a little plank on top
of it and then you put your little metronomes
on top of here and the weak Epsilon coupling
between these uh because this this can can uh the
plank can roll on top of this uh these cylinders
will eventually cause these to synchronize
and so uh what you're and this is
a common phenomena in lots of high
dimensional systems that are weakly
coupled let me keep watching this
so at some point there's going to be a
phase change where they start to synchronize
[Music] it's almost happened you can almost see
now like half of them have started to synchronize
and some of them are out of phase but they're
they're definitely starting to synchronize almost
and it's almost happened now
and the more they synchronize the more they
synchronize so this table you can actually see
the table wobbling now now it's giving a very
strong force in keeping them all synchronized
and this guy over here this
one's my hero that one's not
that one's gonna take the longest to synchronize
that one uh over there is going to take the
longest to synchronize so it doesn't you know
some of these will will take a little while but
you can see that this emergent Behavior Uh does
exist in these systems and sometimes all it takes
is a little Epsilon coupling so that you get this
feedback um to kind of bring them into synchrony
so you know we've known for a long time uh when
soldiers cross a bridge in formation they're
supposed to break uh you know break their their
marching cadence or else they could bring the
bridge down this is this has been known for a long
time you're supposed to break step when you cross
bridges in large groups the Millennium bridge in
London that really cool Bridge walking bridge
with the cool cables that had a weak coupling
so that when people walked across it when one
person stepped and it caused the bridge to move
a little bit to one side everyone else brace
themselves out of phase and caused another
force and those eventually cause everyone to
synchronize just like this and that almost
broke the bridge down everyone had to like drop
on all fours and crawl off because of this kind
of emergent synchronization so I guess the point
I'm trying to make here is that High dimensional
dynamical systems uh can be chaotic they can
be deterministic they can synchronize they can
desynchronize there's a lot of super duper Rich
phenomena in these systems that you can observe
and predict and estimate and control but you know
really understanding how the numerics works and
how you would simulate these in a computer how
small perturbations can grow exponentially you
know those are all really really important this
is a rich field it's one of the most interesting
fields in all of mathematics because it ties
together you know differential equations and
linear algebra and numerics and computation
and physics and it it explains and allows us
to describe the world that we observe around us
which changes in time and evolves according to
rules and has instabilities and synchronizations
and all of it and it's super fascinating I'm glad
you have been with me on this series and I hope I
hope that there are more and that you get you know
interested in in following in some of these these
leads and threads thank you all so much [Music]